and the president of the MCCT, we all
know brother Masood, his mother passed
away a couple days ago,
yesterday I believe in the morning.
And
her janazah will be held today at
salat al-zuhr 12:40.
And then we will head to the cemetery
right after inshallah. Again, that's
today at at salat al-zuhr 12:40.
[Arabic recitation]
al-wajeez fi kitab al-salah
in the chapters regarding the timings of
prayer, mawaqit al-salah.
We've discussed the general framework
for the timing of each prayer, zuhr,
asr, maghrib, isha, and fajr. We We
mentioned the starting time and the
ending time in the narration of Jabir
ibn Abdillah collected by Tirmidhi and
others. And we discussed this narration
and we mentioned that this narration
discusses the idyllic time to pray in
each of the prayers.
The general principle
that the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam gives us is that every prayer
ends at the beginning of the next,
except for Fajr.
Every prayer
ends, its time ends, at the start of the
next prayer, the following prayer.
So, ends at the start of
ends at the start of
of Isha, and Isha ends at the start of
Fajr.
However, Fajr is the only salah that is
the odd one out of that and does not fit
into that general framework. For this
reason, some of the scholars have
considered Fajr to be a salah al-wusta,
the middle
prayer.
However, it's very important for us to
identify
which prayer is a salah al-wusta.
Which prayer is the middle salah?
Because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
said,
[Arabic recitation]
Be mindful guarding
of your prayers and especially the
middle prayer.
So, we have a general command of all
prayers,
but specifically the middle one. So, we
need to identify which is the middle
prayer.
The author says, "A salah al-wusta ma
hi?"
[Arabic recitation]
An Ali radiyallahu anhu qala, "Qala
yawm al-ahzab,
Shaghaluna an al-salat al-wusta, salat
[Arabic recitation]
quburahum naran.
238th verse of Surat al-Baqarah, "And be
mindful
and dutiful
in fulfilling your prayers and
especially the middle prayer."
On the authority of Ali ibn Abi Talib,
he narrates that the messenger of Allah
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said on the
day of al-Ahzab, "The Battle of al-Ahzab
is also known as the Battle of what?"
"The Battle of the Confederates
is also known as the Battle of
Huh?
al-Khandaq, the Trench. The Battle of
the Trench. What was the Battle of the
Trench? Well,
essentially, Medina has different
fronts.
In the backside, there are walls and
villages that were able to protect it.
But, there was one side of it that was
very, very exposed.
And so, being that they did not have
enough
forces to combat the huge amounts of
confederates, it's called the
confederates because all of the known
enemies of the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam at the time
got together.
They could never agree, but they agreed
on this.
Got together and attacked Medina
trying to put an end to the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam and Islam
once and for all.
So, the back end was
protected and mainly occupied by
Banu Banu an-Nadir, a Jewish tribe
that was on the outskirts. They were
into
importation, farming, and arms
dealing. And they had a truce and an
allegiance to the prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam to protect the Muslimin
from that angle. And so Salman al-Farsi
being that he was exposed to
you know, Persian warfare and the
Persians were one of the two superpowers
at the time,
he
posed the suggestion that they should
dig a giant trench
that is
deep enough and long enough that the
military would be impeded if they all
tried to enter all at once. The trench
wasn't all all the way around Medina. It
was just in this part. It was about 15 m
long
and about 6 m deep. So, if you can
imagine this
15 m long and about 6 m deep, 15 m is
probably roughly to where Abu Usama is,
the pillars there.
And so,
if a cavalry or or soldiers tried to get
in, they would have to go down into this
pit.
And this would slow them down enough to
be able to fend them off with arrows.
And if any stragglers get across, they
can be dealt with as they get across.
And so, this is what they did. They dug
the trench and they had to guard this
trench. They had to mind it. And so, the
Muslimin were there and this went on for
about 10 days.
A little over 10 days where they were
fighting and guarding this trench and
they had to take shifts
to mind the trench, right?
And so,
one day
when it became ex- especially
vicious, the fighting,
they had to all be there, and they could
not leave for a moment.
And so, what happened? They continued to
fend them off until the sun set.
They had not prayed Asr yet.
And the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said,
"They have distracted us from the middle
prayer. May Allah fill their homes and
their graves with fire for doing so."
What is the middle prayer based on this
context? Salat al-Asr.
Ali narrates that it is Salat al-Asr
that they collectively missed, and then
they later joined Asr and Maghrib
together when the fighting died down due
to the dark. So, this is the story of
the trench, and this is the strongest
opinion, and it's the opinion of Aisha
radiyallahu anha. In her recitation of
Surat al-Baqarah, she would recite in
one recitation, "Hafizu ala salawati wa
[Arabic recitation]
Nas'al Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala an